hello everyone and welcome to another
interesting game from round two of the
2018 bill chess festival it's a game
between Petrus wheeler and the local
Swiss Grandmaster Niko georgiadis now in
my opinion Peter Svidler is definitely
the best chess commentator in the world
but the problem with him commentating on
an elite chess event is that he is not
playing that elite chess event himself
and I'm very happy that he's playing in
this closed event in such an elite setup
so this is probably well every game is
is always a tough game you have to play
it to the best of your abilities but
here a young Niko is facing definitely a
top top elite Grandmaster and every game
for young Niko is a chance to do
something and to create something now we
don't have a couple of photos from this
event here you have a swimmer it's a
still the opening probably the third or
fourth move very very nice photo I will
put a link to all the photos taken as
there there is an official Dropbox link
from the bill chess festival website so
you will be able to check out all of
them and here also we have a very nice
photo of Peter Svidler it's followed by
Leonhard totes also from the official
bill chess festival website and here so
we don't think that it's just a festival
you know of six players battling it out
here you can see that there are actually
a lot more players playing in the bill
chess first of all the six players we
are covering in this series is only the
main event and that is the closed six
player double round-robin so that being
said let's check out this game sweedler
has the white pieces and he opens with E
for c5 we have the Sicilian defence
Knight f3 d6 and Bishop to be Bishop to
b5 check the canal attack if if instead
of d6 knight c6 was played then this
will of course be the Rosalie management
Dino's Knight to d7 blocking castles and
a6 now either checking if swinger will
give up the bishop pair or he will go
back with the bishop now you could go
Bishop to e2 that
probably something you would expect you
don't you don't want to play butter up
the c4 that would allow b5 with tempo so
here are very interesting move Bishop to
d3 it seems like an awkward move to play
why would you you know willingly block
your own deep on our butts wheeler has
plans of playing C 3 and then depends on
walls by place maybe even bringing this
special over to C 2 and then only then
pushing the D pawn Knight the G to f6
rook to e1 we have e 6a for now
preventing me 5 so b6 preparing to
develop the LightSquared Bishop c3 now
finally making room for that light
square Bishop Bishop to b7 and now comes
Queen to e2 Queen - Queen to c7
developing the Queen and knights to a3
Bishop to e7
and now rush room nuts come to see to
rook the c8 if the C file ever opens
Nico will already have a nice Queen rook
battery and the C file d3 not going for
the immediate d4 you know there's always
time to put up on to d4 it's always you
know nice to wait with these things once
you push a pawn you can never you know
push it back
we have castles Bishop to d2 now
preparing to develop the rooks rook F to
e 8 now comes rook a to C 1 and now II
five so okay a very nice setup in the
center and not allowing sweedler to ever
execute to d4 but fiddler finds another
idea he goes Bishop to b3 and already
you can see that this f7 pawn is
somewhat too weak you know there's
something like Bishop captures on f7 IG
596 could be coming so you do have to
prepare for something like this
h6 definitely you know would would go a
long way here simply blocking ideas like
this but Nico goes for d5 a nice a nice
central central breakthrough and you
know it's always said that if you can
push d5 in the Sicilian and you know
nothing goes wrong then you're doing
well he captures on d5 Knight captures
on d5 and now Queen to e4 seems
dangerous putting a queen on e4
you know right in front of the bishop
but tactics you know
don't don't go
wheeler in this position for example if
you play something like tonight 712 six
attacking the Queen it's not a problem
the Queen is under attack the knight on
d5 is now defended twice and while you
can grab the e5 pawn you can also try to
create some sort of an attack Queen h4
and now after Knight to d7 attacking the
Queen Queen G Queen g4 a knight back to
f6 attacking the Queen Queen g3 now
comes the knight to h5 and basically
black would force white to grab e5 pawn
but that's actually the best thing black
can do here captures captures captures
and after Knight f4 white would simply
win a pawn here so you can't do
something like Knight to f6 in the game
Knight captures and c3 was played a very
interesting idea now sweet lers queen is
under attack both by the knight from c3
and by the Bishop from b7 so what do you
do here first Bishop captures on f7 the
strongest move and you know the the best
idea
King captures on f7 and now Queen to a5
check getting the Queen out of out of
harm's way
and only when the check is blocked or
the King moves will swiller recapture
and c3 King g8 we have Bishop captures
on c3 now there's a triple attack
against the e5 pawn so Neko defends that
push up to f6 now it's defended four
times Knight to c4 finally sweedler gets
his Knight out of that funny a3 square
Queen to c6 and what do you do here okay
now white can definitely grab the e5
pawn but the Bishop of Queen battery is
very nice here on this long diagonal
this Knight can never move as Queen is
eyeing g2 so Knight captors on c5 Knight
cappers on c5 and now Queen to Bishop
captures on e5 Queen captures and and
now Queen Queen to d5 pinning the bishop
on e5 as the Queen and f5 is unprotected
we have rook to e3 the best idea from
Seville are preparing to double up on
the e-file and also the rook will now
help out with the defense of the d3 pawn
Bishop captures on e5 and now you cannot
play Knight captures because again Queen
captures and g2 would be checkmate so
Bishop e5 rook captures on e5 and now
rook captures on e5 Queen captures on e5
and you cannot straight Queens here of
course if Queen captures night chapters
via Larissa a clean pawn this was most
likely resulting in him winning a game
due to due to the extra pawn so after
Queen e5 Queen captures on d3 Nico grabs
the extra pawn and now what do you do
here here a sweeter place the Queen to
e6 check and now you can go
h8 or f8 if you go f8 you would lose the
game in in a terrible way because of
Knight to e5 threatening to grab the
Queen and also deliver checkmate on f7
so after Queen to d5 it seems like black
is now threatening checkmate and forcing
a queen trade but you would you know be
very very disappointed here as a Knight
to d7 check the King has nowhere to go
black is forced to capture the night and
then of course black loses the game so
after Queen e6 we have King to h8 and
now comes the rook to e1 h6 first you
have to create some breathing room for
the king of course or rope to d8 would
have been also okay and only then push
the pawn because you can never for
example capture an f3 the rope will be
under attack on c8 we have h6 h3 now as
we will also create some breathing space
for his King and now b5 we have 92 e5
attacking Nico's Queen on d3 and now
Queen to d5 he tries to exchange Queens
and also threatens checkmate on g2 Queen
to g4 defense checkmate the rock is also
defending the knight on e5 and here
comes King to h7 it's a very important
move you cannot you can never allow
something like Knight to g6 check for
example if you capture on a4 now you
allow Knight g6 check King has to move
of course not here because then you lose
the Queen with check but after King h7
simply the Queen and the rook is under
attack and even if you attack the rook
first to kind of get out of the way rook
e1 the queen guards the rook the Queen
has to move and then Knight captures
rook will win the game so after Queen g4
King h7 not allowing 9g 6th to come with
check we have Queen g6 check King g8 and
now comes f3
no longer having to worry about that
mate threat on g2
Queen d2 attacking Silver's rook Queen
to f7 check King moves and now King to
f1 defending the Rockwood the king queen
d5 again offering a trade of Queens
thriller declines Queen g6 check King
Jade and now comes Knight to g4 a
threatening Knight captures on h6 or if
the Queen doesn't move from d5 even
Knight to f6 check winning the Queen so
Queen to g5 the strongest move that
stops both threats now comes Queen to b6
attacking the undefended Bishop on b7
clean back to d5 and now although white
can win a pawn here easily which
captures captures captures this would be
perfectly fine for white but sweedler
plays an even better move he goes for
the immediate Knight captures an X on h6
would check of course you cannot capture
the night if you capture the night you
get Queen g6 check after King moves you
get Queen captures on h6 which check the
the e-file is completely unavailable to
the king so you have to go back and
after that Ruby 7 is coming and there is
no defense against all of these
checkmates you can give Queen d1
checking moves Queen d4 check but after
King g3 there are no more checks and
there is no stopping Queen to h7
followed by Queen to f7 but even if you
stop Queen from coming to h7 a lot of a
lot of other moves will win as well so
after Knight to age 6 we have King h6 o
king h7 Knight to g4 now a suitor goes
back with the night but now the problem
is he's up he's up a pawn and he he has
a better position rook to f8 and now
although you could immediately go for
rook to e5 followed by a rook to h5 you
have to deal with some checks after
Queen d1 so sweet or first brings his
King to safety
King g1 and it doesn't allow any ideas
here with rook captures on f3 we have
Queen to d4 check King moves and now
although you could try something like
Queen d2 but then rocky 5 comes with the
same idea here Neko goes for the
immediate Bishop captures on f3 g
captures and now rook captures on f3
attacking the h3 pawn and here as
fiddler calculates properly he he sees
that rook captures
h3 is actually perfectly fine for white
and he plays the strongest move Queen to
e6 immediately threatening Queenie four
check the trade Queens now rook captures
on h3 like we said is perfectly fine for
sailor after King G to the rope is under
attack after we moved the rook Queenie
four checks the king and forces a queen
trade and after C four characters
captures white black does have two
points for the for the night but the
position is perfectly fine for white and
the extra piece will prevail in this
position so after Queen e6 we have Queen
to d3 avoiding avoiding this idea now he
has a double attack against the h3 pawn
and now comes in 93 blocking the
connection between the Queen and the
rook and now the Queen from e6 also
guards the h3 pawn be captures only an
a4 and now comes King to g2 attacks the
rook rook f6 attacking spoilers Queen
and now comes Queen to d5 offering a
queen trade Queen g6 check King to h1
and now rook to f2 what do you do here
rook to G once wheeler attacks the Queen
on g6 Queen to h6 now attacking the h3
pawn and now comes rope to g3 the rook
from g3 nicely guards the h3 point but
also protects the night here as the
Queen was also attacking the knight on
e3 we have Queen to f6 and here comes
Queen to d3 check also possible was 94
with this double attack but now Queen to
a5 attacks Villiers Queen and then after
captures captures rook to a3 is coming
and the white would still of course be
better but Svidler finds an even better
way first Queen to d3 check now we have
King to h8 and only now Knight to g4
idea being that now Queen to a5 with the
same idea as we've shown doesn't work
because of Queen to d8 check Queen
blocks and now Queen to h4 check King
Jade and now Knight captures on f2 and
of course you cannot capture the night
because then rope clatters and g7
captures and you lose the Queen and the
game after Knight to g4 we have Queen to
c6 now checking the White King King g1
attacking the rook and now rook captures
on b2 and here it's it's all over feel
even feel free to pause the video here
and find the winning continuation for
white so there you have it I will give
you a couple of seconds is usual for
those of you who were able to do it
congratulations you are an excellent
player and for those who just want to
enjoy the show Queen to d8 check of
course
there's really nothing to do here you
can either give up the Queen or move the
King King h7 now comes Queen to h4 check
King to g8 and here's wheeler plate
Knight to h6 and it was in this position
that an eco your goddess resigned the
game why did you resign well there are a
couple of options for example if you if
you move the King to h7 then you get
Knight f5 check we have King King g8 and
now comes rope captures
King moves to f8 and now Queen to e7 or
h8 will be checkmate on the other hand
after Knight oh-6 check you could go to
h8 but it doesn't help you all that much
Queen to d8 is coming King moves now
comes Quint g8 forcing the King to
capture the night and now Queen to h8
will be checkmate as the rock is
covering the entire G file and lastly
but you know not leastly we have king to
f8 but then it's the shortest variation
Queen d8
check Queen has the block and now rope
to f3 will be checkmate as of course in
the knight is covering g8 so after night
to h6 a very nice idea as wheeler-dealer
wins the game and here I just prepare
these are the standings after round 2
you can see Carlsen in first place with
2 out of 2 that's an amazing result mama
Dara would 1 and a half out of 2 Peter
Svidler 1 and 1/2 out of 2 then we have
Navarro would have Maxine would have and
the nicocure God is still with zero out
of 2 but it's a double round-robin you
know anything and still happen
Nico can still do a lot of damage in
this tournament and it's very
interesting so far swiller is having an
excellent tournament and next round in
round 3 of the 2018 bill chess festival
he faces none other than Magnus Carlsen
and this is a great opportunity for
Carlsen but also for sweedler because
here as you can see I prepared
their current score so far so currently
as littler has a positive score against
Magnus Carlsen as weather beat Carlsen
two times cousin won one game and 12 of
the games were drawn that's considering
classical chess here we have if we
include rapid and exhibition games then
Carson has the score of 11 to 7 against
wheeler with 22 draws but as this is a
classical event here is a very nice
opportunity for call center even out to
the score or perhaps force wheeler to
you know even prolong his score or or
you know to at least draw and keep this
very nice edge so yeah that's the game I
do hope you enjoyed it and that you are
enjoying this well short bill coverage I
would like to thank BQ Oliver Frey
increasing and burning for a
contribution to my channel thanks a lot
I really appreciate it I think all for
watching and I will see you soon
probably with another video from the
Bobby Fischer series but definitely with
the the fiddler Carlson game from round
3 of the bill chess festival thank you
all and I'll see you soon